all right now let's turn to the southern
border where every single day the crisis
yes it's the crisis it is getting worse
and worse
but because joe biden is asleep at the
wheel the administration rolled out an
advisor to address
the ongoing crisis yup crisis
unfortunately for joe she accidentally
well admitted the truth how did that
happen that his policies
are causing the crisis take a look
would you describe what's happening on
the border as a crisis
given how these numbers are spiking so
much week by week
you know i think that i i really i'm not
trying to be cute here but i think the
fact of the matter is
we have to do what we do regardless of
what anybody calls the situation
and and whatever you call it wouldn't
change what we're doing
do you think it's a coincidence that as
soon as trump and his immigration policy
were
on the way out and biden and his stated
policy were on the way in this
historic surge at the border started
well
first of all one of the things i think
is important is we've seen surges before
surges tend to respond to hope
and there was a significant hope
for a more humane policy after
four years of you know pent up demand
so i don't know whether i would call
that a coincidence
a rare moment of truth amid a pack of
lies joining us now with an actual
report from the border
in tucson arizona tonight last week in
in texas
fox news contributor investigative
reporter sarah carter is with us sarah
you've been out all day
tell us what's going on and compare the
differences between texas and
arizona well i got to tell you sean
border patrol agents out here in arizona
and the border patrol union are warning
that this is a serious crisis
not just what we talked about last week
the humanitarian crisis where we see the
surge
of young people crossing into the united
states
over the texas mexico border but here
there's been an exponential increase in
narcotics trafficking
because of that what what's happening
here is we have a enormous drug war on
the other side of the border sinaloa
cartel
controlling mainly this area that we
were at in sasebay
arizona which borders sausage mexico
there's a lot of concern that while our
border patrol agents are spread so thin
dealing with young people they're
actually and the people that are
crossing the border taking care of those
unaccompanied minors and family units
the drug cartels are using the open
spaces because
the biden administration basically
halted the continuation of the border
wall they're using those open spaces to
bring those drugs in
i spent the day with art del cuero he is
the vice president of the southwest
region
for the national border patrol council
and here's what he had to say
what cartel controls this territory so
this being
you know northern sonora just south of
us um the sinaloa cartel
is in charge of this area so guzman has
been his people but now
you know there's a drug there's a
serious drug war going
on just south of us with two different
factors that are fighting each other for
control of this area
those drugs are not just affecting the
border those drugs are going into middle
america
they're going all over the country
affecting kids there is a true epidemic
in this country
when it comes to high school kids and
heroin oh yeah
and it's coming through this border now
they call them all the way
to the end and i'm sure you can see
where that mountain ends up there
right that's smugglers this is what's
crazy that's called smuggler's gulch
right and just north of where we were at
it's called smugglers canyon
and you're seeing more of an increase in
cubans we're seeing an increase in
everything
um that's what people think it's just
central americans
and all those issues but you're getting
people from all over the place
that are coming through here i've heard
romania everywhere romania pakistan
and you don't know who they are and
again
the big issue is who are you not
apprehending
right because they don't operate on a
budget
they don't have a budget right you don't
know how much they're putting into
organizations to come bring people
across and and my biggest fear is
obviously not who we're apprehending
but it is who we're not apprehending and
america needs to understand that
sean shortly after we left the area
near smugglers canyon over 60 people
were apprehended coming
into the country just right around the
corner from where we were at and i just
got the latest numbers uh actually from
the border patrol union of the godaways
those are the people they don't know uh
they weren't able to apprehend they're
guesstimating on how many
this year alone 39
000 got aways is what they're estimating
possibly even closer to 40 000
and i want you to think about this where
we were at in texas in the del rio
sector
they estimated about 17 000 godaways
this year so this
is a crisis in arizona it's a crisis
that they want the american people to
understand and know about
and just remember not everybody's coming
from central america we've got people
from all over the world
cdc says the people americans shouldn't
travel to central america
right now that's what their
recommendation is uh you see a lot of
these images no social distancing no
mask
one town in texas 25 positive rate for
covid
and then you still have not had access
to the cargo containers where children
are being held
with a tiny window with bars on it and
butterflies supposedly on the walls
nobody will let us in is that true well
i
well that is true and i've been talking
to a lot of sources on the ground both
in federal law enforcement people in the
area where those cargo containers are
and they have been told in absolutely no
circumstances that any photographs are
supposed to be leaking from there
they are watching it like a hawk the dhs
is very careful and remember
majorcas refuses that's dhs secretary um
mayorkas
refuses to call this a crisis but he's
now
asking for volunteers to come help out
at the border so go figure you can
imagine the frustration of the federal
agents of the border patrol officials
as well as dea fbi and everybody else
who's working along this border
all right sara carter investigative
reporter at the border again reporting
for us news you won't get from the media
mob about a real crisis when